the Illinois man facing federal charges
for the kidnapping of a Chinese visiting
scholar is set to make his second court
appearance later today
Brent Christianson is his name he's
accused in the June kidnapping of June
jingyang if convicted he could spend the
rest of his life in prison Jiang was a
researcher at the University of Illinois
where Christensen earned a master's
degree she had planned to begin a ph.d
program this fall an awareness shows us
what investigators have learned so far
Anna good morning good morning Brent
Christensen's lawyer told us the 28 year
old is married and was looking for work
at the time of the alleged kidnapping an
FBI affidavit filed in court says
investigators caught him on recorded
audio admitting he kidnapped the young
Chinese woman and held her in his
apartment against her will university
officials confirm the night before brent
Christensen's arrest he attended this
vigil for ying-ying Jiang the Chinese
scholar he's charged with kidnapping my
understanding is that mr. Christiansen
has zero criminal history whatsoever
Evan Bruno is Christensen's attorney
he's obviously in a situation that he
never thought he'd find himself in he's
concerned about his family he's
concerned about his future the last
known image of 26 year old Jiang comes
from this surveillance video taken June
9th the afternoon she disappeared the
FBI says the video shows Jiang getting
into Christensen's car the investigators
affidavit says Christensen admitted to
giving an Asian woman a ride but told
investigators he later let her out of
the car the documents claim a search of
Christensen's black Saturn revealed the
front passenger side appeared to be
cleaner than the rest of the vehicle
possibly indicating an attempt to
conceal or destroy evidence more than
5,600 Chinese students study at the
University of Illinois at
urbana-champaign U of I spokesperson
Robin Kaler says the school is always
working to improve security we already
were buying more security cameras
replacing some of the older ones this
camera caught the car but when we tried
to enhance the image to see the license
plate number the resolution wasn't high
enough to do that Chang's family
journeyed from China to the US to await
news of their
daughter and is staying in university
housing ying-ying had only been on
campus for six weeks but she was in the
line I she'd become part of our family
Christensen is being held in Decatur
Illinois about an hour's drive from
campus
he's expected to appear before a judge
this afternoon to determine whether he
should remain in custody Shang family
members say they will stay in Illinois
until she is found investigators don't
think she's still alive but no body has
been found
Jeff Anna thank you very much